is there really a difference between
being motivated and being inspired I
want to talk about that today
I'm Patrick big David your host of value
taming you know a lot of times you we we
hear the words he's such a great
motivator you know I'm inspired then we
don't really know the difference between
motivation and inspiration right so you
know we think we're motivated but we
really inspired when inspire was really
motivated so what is it really the real
difference and when that question was
asked for me one thing came to my mind
right off the bat to me the biggest
difference between motivation and
inspiration is life span life span of
that feeling of that emotion let me
explain so whatever emotion of
excitement or wanting to take action
that lasts longer it's inspiration
whatever is shorter it's motivation for
instance you know if somebody if you
find yourself saying I'm good at staying
excited for one day or two days or a
week or two weeks but for whatever
reason I can't stay excited for 90 days
or a year or five years or ten years or
twenty years that's because you've only
figured out how to motivate yourself you
have not figured out how to inspire
yourself very very big difference look
to simplify in my understanding to me on
what motivations are such inspiration
motivation is a lot of making statements
inspiration is about asking questions so
if you want to motivate somebody would
say things like you can do with your
grade you're awesome this is for you
you're going to go make a difference you
know that's a lot of motivation a lot of
inspiration is what do you want to do
you know where do you want to go why are
you doing this so think about the most
popular motivation phrase in the world
that we've all used or heard before is
what you can do it right just like from
this scene and this movie
doing as funny as Rob Schneider's and
waterboy you know you can do it is being
used in many different movies right but
you know if I was to think about what
question is a question that makes us
think you know what is in most common
question to ask to inspire somebody is
what is what do you want just like in
this scene which is the most powerful
scene to me in this movie notebook when
he asks the question from her
what easy way there is no easy way no
matter what I do somebody gets hurt
would you stop thinking about what
everyone wants stop thinking about what
I want what he wants what your parents
want what do you want what do you want
it's not that simple what do you want
you know I love this scene I love this
scene because I've seen it so many times
no one just doesn't stop and you know
you have Ally on one end where her
parents you know are trying to motivate
her and they want her to do what they
want her to do not what she wants to do
motivate to marry the right guy you know
marry the right this and all this kind
of stuff and Noah tried motivating so
long and it didn't work and you just
said look what do you want and when you
inspire people it all becomes about them
less about you you're inspiring them
what do you want what is it worth you
making a decision and giving everything
you got in your life to go after one
thing what do you want not you can do
this you can do it you can do this all
this stuff because remember a motivator
doesn't necessarily inspire others but
someone who inspires automatically
motivates others because you're sitting
there and a person start asking
questions you know what's your purpose
of living meaning you know when when
when you sit there and you think about
all the events that happen in your life
and one of my flights I was coming back
and I started writing on this fly one of
the most incredible exercises I started
writing
most difficult things that ever happen
in my life that that impacted me
emotionally whether it's my insecurities
my fears my flaws my vice my challenge
my mistakes and everyone's got it
everyone's good we don't want to talk
about this but everyone's got it right
and I made a list very emotional very
emotional flight I have those notes till
today events days I clearly remember
that crushed me or hurt me or challenged
me or whatever it was and I started
connecting the dots you know this
happened because it is that happened
because it is this happened because it
is maybe there's a bigger picture to the
whole thing maybe there's a bigger
picture to the whole thing and why did
this happen what about this what do I
want what motivates you what fires you
up what gets you going that's the
questions to ask to inspire you to
realize the bigger calling in life you
know I got two books I want to share
with you here one of them is the
accidental millionaire you know I love
this book The Accidental millionaire
I love accidental millionaire because
Lee butcher who wrote this book he wrote
this book and it did very well during
that time because he wrote it right
after Steve Jobs got fired and if you
read this book the reason why I love
this book is because he writes the book
without the story being finished yet see
he writes the book the rise and fall of
Steve Jobs at Apple computers you can
tell when you read it that author
doesn't like the character which is
Steve Jobs but what he doesn't
understand is Lee butcher guy what he
doesn't understand is Steve Jobs was
inspired and you know what can stop
somebody who's inspired and the
inspirational level is very high you
know what can stop it very few things
very very few things I'm talking I mean
you know Armageddon and things like that
very few you can't get in a way of a
human being who is genuinely and
sincerely inspired you can write
whatever you want about that person
criticize them a million different times
spread a million different rumors
you can't stop somebody who's inspired
you cannot stop somebody who's inspired
you cannot like this other book called
the answer to history by the Shah of
Iran when he wrote this book he wrote
this book right before he passed away so
he's got cancer he's on his deathbed
he's about to pass away he writes this
book one of the reasons why I love this
book a chapter of it I mean I can't read
this book enough times it says you know
a little later in someone's own
conception I fell okay a little later
during summer on my way to Imams I did I
would a place of pilgrimage in the
mountains I fell from a horse my horse
on the rocks and passed out I was taken
for dead but I had not so much as a
scratch in falling I had a vision of one
of our saints a boss who cradled me as I
fell and he continues this dream and
vision were followed sometimes I bought
an appreciation for that - a mere on
royal palace and he explains it
continues and in chapter 6 he says this
under her tutelage I began dreaming or
dreams
unusual for a boy my age who stock
matters French teacher we taught him how
to speak French many different things in
life and he says but then I already knew
that I would not lead the life of an
ordinary boy thus I dreamed of making my
country's peasants happy and having
every man judged by the laws by just
laws these were dreams that never left
me never left me
never inspiration never left me in which
to a large degree I managed to realize
later in life he was asking questions
about his life Who am I why is my father
reza Han why do I have a boy why am I in
this situation here why is Iran going
through this mess here I used to be one
of most beautiful places in the world
the wealthiest people used to go to Iran
for vacation you know Frank Sinatra
would do concerts there Elizabeth Taylor
would go there and visit you know the
The Ambassadors are heavy and a lot of
things would happen with Iran I mean it
was one the top three countries in the
world for tourism in the 70s what
happened he was inspired a man was
inspired
you can stop neither one of them they
both died from cancer in their 50s they
were inspired
they were not motivated when you're
inspired motivation is automatic when
you're inspired and it's a bigger
calling and the way you know it is how
long you stay excited like this is I am
really excited that means it's real
inspiration I'm not excited today you're
not inspired you just motivated you know
many years ago I was thinking about
becoming a motivational speaker okay so
my I was looking up to this guy and I
said one anyone become a motivational
speaker and when it came down to it I
had an interview in San Diego 6:30 in
the morning the lady called Cynthia hey
we want to hire you we're gonna give you
multi 650 or you're gonna do this you're
gonna do the intertribal you gonna get
all this stuff twenty four years old and
I had such a hard time sleeping that
night I went to sleep and I called in a
warning I'm not showing up why I don't
want to motivate I want to inspire I
don't want to be a motivational speaker
I want to inspire and I will never
forget that completely change the way I
view things because all night that night
I was asking questions and over the
years I put a list of questions together
that I asked about you know figuring
yourself out and I won't share all of
them with you but what I'll do is I'll
put a list of the questions that I'll
share with you maybe we can put a link
on the bottom to a website we can go and
see some of the questions and maybe I'll
put some of the other questions later on
but I'll make a list of you can click on
a link bottom description I'll make sure
that some of the questions that I've
asked myself on my life but I want her
to be inspired I want it to be inspired
and you know what else is so crazy you
do as well you also want to be inspired
you also want to go out there and do
something special and the best test to
know about excitement about motivation
versus excitement is what motivation
versus inspiration is how long do you
stay excited do you need alarm clocks to
wake you up inspiration you don't need a
wrong clocks you just flip and wake up
in the morning because you're inspired
because you're connecting the dots and
you're realizing life has a bigger
meaning to than just making a million
bucks and driving a Ferrari or Porsche a
Lamborghini and there's nothing wrong
with having all of that stuff that's
fine but on your way to fulfill
prophecy your prophecy your crusade your
cause your vision that that's from here
that's from your life experience that's
from the crap that's happened to you you
can't tell me you go to sleep every
night thinking you're supposed to be a
virgin ordinary you can't tell me that I
don't buy that and I don't think you do
either and I think you need to ask
yourself a lot more questions that lead
to action that leads to excitement for a
long period of time until your time
comes that you pass away and you write a
book and millions of people know about
it and you fulfill your prophecy but it
won't happen by just trying to get
motivated and nothing wrong would be
motivated you need a lot of motivation
believe me motivation is a great thing
going I'm not telling you don't use the
phrase you can do it or doll this none
that at all that's needed everyday we
need motivation you know even a Martin
Luther King go was inspired he needed
some people to motivate him at times but
he knew his prophecy his calling was a
bigger calling look what he did to the
world
that's inspiration she wanted a list of
questions click on the link on the
bottom if you got any other questions
about the message hear comments please
comment on the bottom filter I'd ask any
questions we actually do read the
questions and get back to you on the
questions as well but uh a challenge to
you is really think about this when you
finish the video don't go to another
video just stay on it for a second and
think about ask the question what do you
want what are you here for what are you
supposed to do you what are you supposed
to do not the other guys block everybody
else what's the reason why you're
supposed to make money doesn't mean
leave your job it means use whatever
money you're making to fulfill your
calling what is your calling what is
that private time when you're by
yourself upset frustrated ticked off you
want to curse out the world but you
really want to curse yourself back
because you're so furious with yourself
and typically when you're furious with
yourself you kind of feel like you're
not doing what what's yours what is your
calling what can you do to inspire you
to take action
go ahead and do that exercise privately
wait at night with everybody away you by
yourself with you and then whatever
business you're in whatever money you're
making use that money that you're making
to fulfill your prophecy to fulfill your
calling
it's my message of the week to you
thanks for watching please be sure to
subscribe this to this channel and also
share the video with some people would
also get value from this message
take care